hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm Kat Alvarado Kat Alvarado the
comedian with the podcast villains of
history has returned guys go check out
her podcast free to listen to on iTunes
that's right I listen to it and that's
where I appear on it
what's just on they're talking about the
Gainesville Ripper she was talking about
with me the person who inspired the
Amityville Horror mythology and such
Jamie Kennedy was on there recently some
guy from Mean Girls it's growing
exponentially
it's doing every video has lent a word
that I have said that you have realized
Greg's vocabulary you may have slightly
increased doing such a good job training
you Soros at night I'm gonna watch this
key MPO video substitute teacher this is
like some classic sketch I love camping
I don't have Comedy Central so I've only
seen like a lot of key and Peele videos
through YouTube so case in point what's
happening right now let's watch this mr.
Garvey I taught school for 20 years in
the inner city so don't even think about
mess with me y'all feel me okay let's
take roll here Jay Quellin
which de aquila net no Jay Quellin here
do you mean Jacqueline okay okay take
wasn't but lucky
where is Malacca air
no but lucky here today my name is Blake
Park and you out of your goddamn mind
make what do you want to go to war my
lucky cuz we could go to war I'm for
real real so you better check yourself D
nice to see nice if one of y'all says
some silly-ass name this whole class is
gonna feel my wrath nice you mean Denise
you said your name right right now
Denise say right Denise correctly Denise
right Denise what a night that's better
now thank you
now hey Ron where are you where is
ay-ay-ron right now no way Ron huh well
you better be sick dead or mute
ay-ay-ron here oh yeah why don't you
answer me the first time I sit down huh
you know I'm just asking I said it like
[Laughter]
Oh big words
Timothy reason Pio made it appear yeah
oh man I've never seen that sketch it's
so good that's such a simple concept and
yet so damn funny he's so funny oh my
god just goes to show you don't have to
like think so hard about being funny so
I don't know if you guys know this but I
am a comedian seriously there are some
really interesting books out there about
creativity and improv I don't know if
I'm taking this too seriously
but please this book called improv has
this concept in there about when you're
writing comedy not to think so hard like
a lot of times people try to be funny
and so they think about the same thing
that everyone else thinks up because
when everybody's trying to be funny they
kind of end up at the same point hmm but
if you look at your own life and like
what's right in front of your face
you'll actually end up with something
really unique and somehow I feel like
that sort of applies in this sense
because of the simplicity of it it's
just right there they didn't think too
overly hard about the concept so there
is something brilliant about the
simplicity of it you can't pronounce
people the reversal is so great because
in real life it's the other way around
yeah it has like an ethnic name well I
thought was Great Britain they can't say
it so like if they couldn't say white
people's names I thought was great too
is because they did the rule of three
already where you did three kids right
and then they get to the fourth one Hey
and I was like well the jokes done now
right but then to have it be that he's
pissed that they didn't call him I guess
the good to have this student be like I
don't want to correct him because he's
just gonna get mad at me he would be
hesitant and for him to get mad at him
for being hesitant I thought it was a
really smart comedy right there I'm not
like a perfect but into for the present
ah yeah sometimes you ever like they
talk about the rule of three but there's
also the rule of keep doing it which
works for three or the rule of non-stop
comedy I've got one word okay it's a
it's a what what if a sloth has an itch
on it like what if a sloth had to itch
itself and I just like slowly do this
like and I just keep it going for like
ever and there's three laughs in there
believe it or not there's the initial
stupid laugh then there's the laughs of
oh it's still going and then if I keep
it going just long afterward like almost
steps right here for a while then there
is a third uncomfortable laugh so this
one dumb joke gets three laughs which is
cool just because of that keep doing it
and commit to the bit rule it's comedy
man oh absolutely it's a science it's a
science and I love it the other thing
that I love about this if you really
want the innards of comedy I've been
taking Graham links I've been to ground
links and one of the things they say at
Groundlings is you can't control a lot
in improv but the one thing you can't
control is commitment and emotion and
that's the thing that he is so good at
is the commitment
he's just heightened emotion what that
brings in the comedy it is absolutely
great what do you mean by the emotion
like the one thing commitment and
emotionally yes how would you act in
like a real oh well sorry I said your
name wrong he could be like damn it but
no he's like oh that's your phone over
okay it was my phone
your watch okay turn around okay I mean
I can't just learn don't break my mirror
just like the bottom part I feel like
taking comedy lessons from you know he's
the most energy I've ever seen you have
in a video ever so they have that
footage of you doing the sloth bit I
have a stand-up comedy footage I don't
how long is that bit take you to do how
like 20 seconds okay we could go check
out cats three minutes set of flappers
where's 20 seconds so that three minutes
is dedicated to the swamp go to cattle
Verado
dot-com slash events and you'll see my
shows come see me live sometime if I'm
in your town maybe I'll do this loft bed
maybe you'll catch it
we'll see I'm sure some of our
subscribers would love to have
one-on-one tutoring comedy sessions from
you you know what then DM me on
Instagram yeah I look actually at all my
messages that I get not gonna lie yeah
well done I mean I won't come over but
maybe we could do like a Skype thing I'm
gonna save you right now subscribe to
the rejects
check out Kats podcast villains of
history follow on social media you have
permission to DM her now guys but just
like keep it keep it ranking don't don't
you know it's on none of it none of that
could you know none of that okay we got
it
what are you talking about don't send me
pictures of your junk I don't know a
single girl I mean like I said like
she's single I mean like I don't know
one female ever who has gotten a picture
of a random dick oh I'm social media and
it's been like [ __ ] I gotta have sex
with this thing it's like guys we'll get
photos of you
who's this girl check her out but I've
never seen her identity gets robbed oh
my god that's a technique that means you
they just like send boobs no be more yes
yes
push with it I've never heard of a girl
being like this thing I've never heard
of that happening so do that with Kat
and let's see if it works oh you can't
because Instagram blur stuff out I don't
even see it so check out my pocket